we have uh two absolutely huge stories
to start with today
and uh i wasn't sure which to start with
but let's just start with the first one
we have now learned that apple
has given the trump or gave at the time
the trump administration
information and documents on democratic
lawmakers and this is yet another
attempted or real abuse of subpoena
power
to obtain documents about the political
enemies of the trump administration and
we also
of course have to consider the role uh
which apple itself
has played let's take a look at an
article from thomson reuters which says
apple on friday said it has tightened
some of its rules for responding to
legal requests
after the u.s justice department during
donald trump's presidency
subpoenaed it for information on
democratic lawmakers
apple said it recently instituted a
limit of 25
identifiers such as email addresses or
phone numbers
per legal request so so far what they're
saying is
if you're going to do this you'll have
to make multiple requests you can't give
us a list of 100
identifiers you'll have to give us four
four lists of 25.
the cupertino california-based company
said it received a subpoena from the
justice department in february 2018
for information on 109 identifiers made
up of 73 phone numbers and 36
email addresses but that it did not
release content such as emails and
pictures
to prosecutors the new york times on
thursday
reported and we will get to that report
that federal prosecutors subpoenaed
apple and other companies as part of an
investigation searching for the sources
behind media news reports about contacts
between trump's associates and
russia this is a key line what was the
point of this
what was it that the trump
administration the trump justice
department
was seeking to find out in requesting
this information
they were trying to uncover the sources
the journalistic sources for reporting
about trump administration contacts with
russia think back to when
this was going on and there were reports
about
jeff sessions said there were no
contacts but look at all these contacts
that we found
uh donald trump said there were no
contacts uh you know the whole list of
these people
so the trump administration through the
justice department said hey you know
what
let's start figuring out let's get
information from people's iphones and
from the i cl from uh uh the icloud
whatever else was being used right
uh related to apple or possibly being
used let's see if we can figure out
who the sources are or were for what
these reports are claiming trump
publicly saying oh anonymous sources no
no no
they're just bogus but privately they
knew they weren't bogus
so much so that they were trying to
figure out exactly who they were
publicly saying when you read anonymous
source
doesn't exist there's no one there's no
real source
privately understanding there are
sources and trying to figure out
exactly who those people are the
investigation targeted at least two
democrats on the house of
representatives intelligence committee
aides and family members including one
minor the new york times reported apple
said it had no way to tell what the
nature of the investigation was
and released only basic account
subscriber information such as names
addresses email addresses phone numbers
as well as connection logs and ip
addresses apple said it did not provide
data showing
to whom or when messages of any kind
were sent the new york times
then reporting the justice department
subpoenaed apple
for information in february 2018 about
an account
that belonged to donald f mcgann ii
president donald j trump's white house
counsel at the time
this is another wrinkle to this story
this is another aspect
which we'll we're still trying to figure
out for the most part it seems what was
going on here
was an attempt to figure out who were
the sources for the news media
presumably on the democratic side about
these different
contacts that the trump campaign and
administration had with russians but at
the same time
the new york times report points out
that um
there was an attempt to get information
about donald trump's lawyer
as well and the new york times article
says it was not clear
what fbi agents were investigating
whether mr mcgann was their specific
focus
or whether he was swept up in a larger
net because he had communicated with
someone who was under scrutiny that's
another important aspect to understand
there are some on the right saying this
was not a partisan
thing being done by trump loyalists in
the justice department
looking for information only on
democrats as evidenced by the fact
that they were looking for information
about trump's own lawyer
what it may have been and if it is it's
absolutely crazy
that there was some other person being
scrutinized imagine that there was just
as a hypothetical some russian national
that was sort of at the center of this
the justice department may have been
saying we need information on anybody
who's been in touch with this person
and apple may have seen a connection
between mcgann
and that individual and so incidentally
mcgann may have been swept up on it we
just don't know at this point in time is
the point
now meanwhile as reported by cnn's
manu raju who tweeted over the weekend
quote
barr sessions and now rosenstein
say they were unaware of the subpoenas
sent under their tenure
for democratic lawmakers records
these are three people with a track
record of dishonesty first of all so i
wouldn't trust them much
but what seems to be going on here is
that they are trying to get their
stories straight
for one word answers if they're ever
forced to testify how
nobody knew anything all of these
subpoenas were were filed
but nobody knew who who authorized them
who signed we just don't know
the administration was granted
years-long gag orders
against these subpoenas same as the
others these were gag
orders that were renewed multiple times
what judge okayed the renewal of the gag
order
on the fact that these subpoenas were
signed off on and granted
which judge or judges were involved do
we need to subpoena
the subpoenas to figure out who is
behind some of this stuff
it is an incredible story um
it did not make the headlines i might
have guessed it would have made or that
that i would have hoped it would make
but a major story
which we are going to continue following
one of the best ways that you can
support what we do at the david pakman
show is supporting some of our awesome
sponsors today one of those awesome
sponsors is sheath
underwear a lot of us know all too well
about the sticking and the rubbing and
the chafing with traditional
underwear especially this time of year
as the weather is getting warm
sheath underwear have created unique
boxer briefs with
multiple ergonomic compartments in the
front
preventing skin on skin contact
everything stays
separate comfortable dry and cool
no more sweatiness no more chafing no
more readjusting it's a lifesaver
sheath underwear is giving the david
pakman show audience
20 off when you go to sheath underwear
dot com slash pacman
and use the promo code pacman give
sheath underwear a shot
i've had a great experience i believe
you will too you can find the link
underneath this video and don't forget
to use promo code
pacman for 20 off